10 uhr 30 vormittags und die fast 400
freiwilligen drängeln sich um endlich
rein zu dürfen ins terminal dabei ist in
zeiten von corona abstarb geboten
doch echte flughafen fans hält das nicht
von einem tag als komparse im neuen
hauptstadtflughafen ab ich bin flugzeug
begeistert ich bin reise begeistert und
ich lasse mir natürlich so eine
gelegenheit nicht entgehen
viele schon geflogen die original klage
von 65
schau mal was davon übrig geblieben ist
so will ich mal sehen wie das
funktionieren soll
insgesamt 9000 freiwillige sind seit
anfang juli im einsatz zwei mal die
woche wird getestet
die koffer sind unterschiedlich schwer
bepackt schließlich soll das szenario
echt sein und da fangen die komplikation
für manche schon an
wird es ein flop
jeder noch so kleine fehler sollen heute
gefunden werden
am ende des tages geben die komparsen
ihr urteil ab pünktlich ende oktober
soll der flughafen in betrieb genommen
werden aber die aussichten sind den
zeiten von kogit 19 düster das ist
extrem passagiereinbruch den wir
natürlich jetzt erleben wir sind so um
die 25 passagier zahlen
das ist natürlich aus wirtschaftlicher
sicht extrem schlimm also inbetriebnahme
sich erleichtert das natürlich ein
bisschen dass wir mit geringerer
verkehrslast an den start gehen können
aber das kann dann gerne auch nach zwei
tagen alles wieder wieder weg sein
geübt wird auch ein verkehrsunfall und
der schnelle einsatz der feuerwehr
die flughafengesellschaft ist mit dem
tag zufrieden man verbessere sich
täglich und das obwohl längst noch nicht
alles so richtig fertig ist für die
geschäfte sind noch verwaist und die
komparsen bis jetzt ganz gut besetzt
sperre beck die abfertigungs dame sagt
die nach rechts der spargel wird
schalter hat nichts angenommen also
durch die ganze halle nach links also im
echtzeitbetrieb auch die abfertigung
sicherheitskontrolle und so war es
ziemlich langsam den flughafen mit
extrem langen weg also dann müssen wir
den passagieren darauf aufmerksam machen
vielleicht inventuren schon und nicht in
den usa und am flughafen zu kommen
ein extrem langer weg und viele jahre
hat es bis zur eröffnung gedauert
in knapp acht wochen soll es aber
endlich soweit sein und die ersten
flieger starten können